موقع Voda Baccano op
رفيق المرشد الأعلى الذي ينظم الميدان
قائد الفرقة الإستراتيجية الاقتصاد الاستعماري والتكتلات الإستراتيجية الأخرى للجيش الشعبي الكوري مرحب بها
فعلت
1 year yo 04:00 3 غزو اللوائح المذكورة أعلاه داخل سرب عمليات بيونغ يانغ
مع وحدات المدفعية الإستراتيجية للجيش الشعبي الكوري المكلفة بالضرب
استراتيجية المسافات الطويلة صاروخ Pando باتونج ذوقي ليس جيدًا
اذهب بعيدًا ، انظر إلى جورجيا ، جنبًا إلى جنب مع الجيش الشعبي الكوري ، وهي استراتيجية بعيدة المدى
التدريب على قاعدة الصاروخ في اتجاه واحد هو شرفنا مع معنى ووزن الجرس.
Eulji Freedom Guardian Military Joint Military Ian Tbe
وقد نُظمت في إطار مظاهرة دايوونغ المسلحة استعدادًا لها
التدريبات التي تستغرق دقيقتين هي استجابة لجميع الشكوك حول مرض الحمى القلاعية في شبه الجزيرة الكورية 10 مرة أخرى
رقابة الموقف
لتأكيد القدرات التشغيلية للصاروخ الاستراتيجي أحادي الاتجاه متوسط ​​المدى بعيد المدى
لهذا السبب ، تقدمت مع عمود العدو ويؤلمني أن أضرب.
التقديم الأول في عاصمة بلدنا بأمر من رفيقنا أقدم اللعين غير الرقيق
سياسي لا يمكن تسميته مثل قلوب جنود مشاة المريخ الذين تم تدريبهم.
كنت طويل القامة مع الحماس
تعريف أقدم رفيق سخيف ، يخدم في الظلام الدامس عند الفجر
إعلان عن عقبات سيارة Casio Mars cb لقاذفة الصواريخ حجر جديد الآن
راقب السلوك الخدمي الحيوي لجنود التربة في هواسونغ الذين يطورون ويستعدون للحصول على الدكتوراه
كان يعلم أنه انحنى بخفة حركة ودقة وهو ينظر إليه.
أقدم محترم Do-Ja-Jeong ، ثم رئيس كتالوج Gris Strategy 1 Hector Bal
4 ـ مجموعة موسوعات رعوية مدارية بجوار البحيرة اقتصاديًا يجب أن تكون باردة حسب الترتيب
أنت فعلت ذلك
أوه أوه أوه